the [__] you never got to do and I
thought it was a great idea you were
going to spend an entire day like up in
a glass Booth billboard with Jayla in a
box right in a box yes you had this idea
was this your idea most of us come from
the incredible garage room but this one
was actually mine I don't even know
where it came from but I remember where
I was when I was driving home where JLo
had a big documentary there was going to
be this big billboard that was going to
be on Sunset Boulevard and what we've
got told is that Jayla would really love
to do something around
the fact that this bill but we've done
carpools we're there we've done she's
done come on the show a bunch of times
she was like she'd love to do something
where we could incorporate that
billboard in the bit somehow and I was
like well why don't we suspend a glass
box
over the billboard hey and JLo and I
will live in it for a day we'll be in
there all day a bit like when David
Blaine did it in London and he was in
there for obviously like 50 days or
something crazy and I was like well rig
it with small GoPro cameras we'll have
like a couch in there and we'll just
hang out we can even like a live stream
a bit you know and then um
and then I think something changed in
JLo's diary and the only what day that
we could legally suspend this there had
to be some special permits anyway
logistically it went away but I was I
was kind of I would have been good real
fun yeah and I guess you would have done
some like [__] up stuff in the in the
back just people staring at you and
talking to you yeah and all that stuff
and then we try and have people we were
going to see if like Ben Affleck would
just come and pop in for half an hour
maybe Deliver us our lunch and things
like that and we would bring you know
we'd bring someone in and we'd both try
and draw them or you eat something
really foul and then you pass wind in
the box with JLo I mean it would be
great to be hardly anymore
yeah
foreign